schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
und gut dass er so früh dabei seid denn
wir haben ein spannendes vor heute wir
werden gemeinsam mit euch heute die
rückkehr des deutschen astronauten
matthias maurer zurück zur erde
verfolgen und nach einem halben jahr
kehrt er jetzt zurück in zurück zu uns
auf die erde nach einem halben jahr im
all und vor wenigen minuten konnten wir
schon den sogenannten orbit byrne
beobachten da haben wir auch bilder die
hoffentlich vorliegen können zusammen
jetzt erstmal in die raumkapsel schauen
dort sitzt er gemeinsam mit seinem us
amerikanischen kollegen auf dem weg
zurück zur erde so sieht also da drinne
geradeaus das ist eine insgesamt rund 24
stündige reise von der raumstation iss
zurück zu uns auf die erde und wir
können jetzt gemeinsam in den nächsten
minuten vielleicht dauert auch am ende
insgesamt eine stunde rund gemeinsam
verfolgen wie also matthias maurer und
seine kollegen hoffentlich sicher im
meer vor florida in den usa landen und
wir können gemeinsam mit
weltraumexperten über diese landung und
mars mission sprechen deswegen schalten
wir jetzt direkt mal ins deutsche luft
deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
so heißt es nach oberpfaffenhofen zu
dieter sabbat und thomas uhlig schönen
guten morgen ihr
könnt natürlich eure fragen live stellen
bei uns im stream und die beiden
kollegen können also diese fragen für
uns beantworten denn die beiden kollegen
in oberpfaffenhofen haben an dem
raumlabor columbus an dem also matthias
maurer auf dem matthias maurer
gearbeitet hat auch mitgearbeitet und
ihr könnt uns bestimmt heute morgen
erzählen was da jetzt genau gerade
passiert in diesem moment da oben noch
ich irgendwo in der luft
ja also vor circa 15 minuten vor der die
oft geführt und das seitdem befindet
sich die kapsel auf dem weg nach unten
der atmosphäre und in den usa zehn
minuten wird dann die kapsel die
erdatmosphäre den rand erreichen werde
ich nicht genau definierte sagen was
sagt 27 kilometer und habe da wird um
die erde dazwischen kräfte und dann
merkten die astronauten auch das außen
sozusagen der luft ist und die rüttelt
an fahrzeugen und dann beginnt er eine
entscheidende zeit zeit deswegen ist ja
und du hast du schon wir haben es schon
angesprochen die astronauten sind schon
eine ganz schöne zeit unterwegs seit 24
stunden eigentlich für 24 stunden haben
sie von der iss abgelegt sind
losgeflogen und sind seither unterwegs
haben sich langsam erst von der iss
entfernt
mit einigen kleinen entzündungen und
diese ganzen zündungen die jetzt erfolgt
sind sind eben in vorbereitung darauf
dass dieser die orbit bern stattgefunden
hat der inzwischen auch schon in der
vergangenheit liegt und gut gegangen ist
wir haben hier eine live kommunikation
mit unserem kontrollraum der hier hinter
uns liegt und haben da eben mitgekriegt
der die orbit byrne der eine sehr
kritisches manöver ist wie schon gesagt
hast täter hat auch soweit geklappt und
wie erwartet stattgefunden da hätte ich
eine frage zu dem orbit byrne vielleicht
das müssen wir vielleicht kurz erklären
warum es das so kritisch dass wir das
kurz noch mal besprechen
natürlich gegen die flugrichtung gemacht
werden damit ab bremseffekt eintritt
sonst wird die kapseln er in höhere
höhen transportiert also ich muss nach
unten fliegen das heißt das es muss ein
abbremsen da impuls sein gegen die
flugrichtung dann muss die richtung
stimmen und natürlich auch die größe des
impulses wenn er zu klein ist dann
reicht in die höhen änderung nicht aus
und die atmosphäre zu erreichen wenn
dazu groß ist würde die kapseln in einem
zu steilen winkel eintreten was die
hitzeentwicklung erhöhen würde
eigentlich ist das eine ziemlich coole
sache ich tipp da wirklich in dem
tatplan einmal kurz auf die bremse und
durch dieses kurz auf die bremse tippen
lege ich fest wo und wann ich dann lande
also danach passiert eigentlich nichts
mehr das wird die orbit bern ist das was
definiert volante ich unglaublich und
deswegen ist er natürlich
abschied von den kollegen im all um 7
uhr 20 mitteleuropäischer zeit beginnt
gestern matthias maurers rückkehr zur
erde die dragon kapsel endurance stockt
von der iss ab und begibt sich auf eine
fast 24 stündige reise wie eine
animation des herstellers spacex zeigt
in der erdumlaufbahn wird das
versorgungsmodell abgetrennt beim
eintritt in die atmosphäre heizt sich
die außenseite der kapsel auf etwa 1600
grad celsius auf rund 5700 meter über
dem meer öffnen sich die fallschirme
matthias maurer wird die erde wieder aus
nächster nähe sehen kann bis die in
münster in wenigen minuten ist es so
weit vor der küste floridas im meer
landen wird
also der beitrag von meinem kollegen
pablo selena hier sollte jetzt gerade
nicht zu unhöflichen unserem gespräch
dazwischen kommen aber trotzdem spannend
was wir natürlich gerade gesehen haben
diese reise der kapsel und wir hatten
auch gerade darüber gesprochen dass das
ja eigentlich so ein spannender moment
ist also dann den wir schon erlebt haben
der orbit bern und das dadurch bestimmt
werden kann wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe wo genau und wie die
kapsel auf der erde landet richtig
ja es ist genau das bestimmt den den
landepunkt ab diesem zeitpunkt hat man
keine großen möglichkeiten mehr den
landepunkt zu ändern man hat natürlich
noch kleinen triebwerke auf der kapsel
die eben die steuerung übernehmen aber
dieser der eigentliche bahn impuls und
der der bahn verlauf ist dann bis zu der
landung in tampa vor der küste von tampa
florida dann festgelegt also matip
einmal kurz auf die bremse und weiß dann
100 kilometer genau wie man die
parklücke reinfinden dass das eigentlich
schon genannt werden und dass man bei
verschiedenen missionen wurde ja dann
schon gesagt ja jetzt ist das newton am
steuer weil das eben eine vorbestimmte
von der physik vorgegebene basis auf der
man sich dann befindet und die muss man
eben vorher gut berechnen dass man eben
weiß wo man sich hinbewegt und dass man
eben am ende der bahn auch die richtige
das richtige ziel erreicht wir zeigen
übrigens jetzt auch ein counter an denen
wir einen blenden und euch die ganze
zeit über also die zeit runter zählen
lassen bei der wir erwarten dass also
die kapsel auf der erde landet jetzt
können wir das alle dann mitverfolgen
und gemeinsam immer wieder auf den
countdown schauen ich habe übrigens
gesehen es gibt die erste frage bei uns
im stream bei youtube von jonas voll
mehr er möchte gerne wissen was für g
kräfte wirken auf die astronauten im
vergleich zum start in den orbit
die sind ungefähr vergleichbar die
dragon kapsel soll ungefähr 35 bis 45 g
erzeugen bei wiedereintritt und das
dürfte auch ungefähr in dem bereich sein
der beim aufstieg erzeugt wird die
höhere lasten würden da nur entstehen
wenn eben beim start zu einem launcher
bord wie vor vier jahren war das sind
dann haben wir höhere lasten aber die
meisten kapseln bewegen sich in der
richtung die von 3 bg die eben ganz gut
durch die ersten lauten dann auszuhalten
sind zumindest für die kurze zeit von
drei bis zehn minuten in denen die
auftreten vielleicht muss man für die
nicht physiker mal erklären was das gehe
eigentlich heißt ja das ist guter
vorschlag also 3g heißt die 3 fache
erdbeschleunigung und wie jeder der
schonmal achterbahn gefahren ist der hat
sicher schon zweig oder so was gespürt
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr bei
den großen achterbahnen also da kann man
ungefähr dann ermessen wie cool wie hoch
die last ist da drückt seinem land schon
den sitzreihen und in bonn körpergewicht
mit dem dreifachen körpergewicht genau
und dann muss was ich aber nur
vorstellen bei der achterbahn ist das
vielleicht 43 sekunden und die matthias
maurer und seine kollegen und
kolleginnen müssen dass drei minuten bis
vier minuten aushalten das ist also das
ist der große unterschied dass es eben
nicht aufhört und die nächste
entlastung kommt sondern die belastung
ist dann für mehrere minuten beim
wiedereintritt es müssen ja immerhin
auch die geschwindigkeit von 28.000
stundenkilometern am ende bis auf null
wenn sie nämlich auf der erde landen
abgebaut werden und das erfordert einen
ziemlich langen und ziemlich intensiven
bremsweg das ist eigentlich wie bei
autos und wie hart fühlt sich das dann
an wenn man also im wasser mit der
kapsel landete
das ist natürlich auch noch ein eindruck
der entsteht aber durch die
wasserlandung ergibt sich automatisch
ein gewisser verzögerungseffekt das also
kein harter aufprall die auf der land
ist wie bei der sus kapseln die ja noch
mal durch raketen versucht diesen
aufprall ein bisschen abzudämpfen aber
das wasser ist das sehr gnädig und gibt
einem die kapsel taucht ein bis zwei
meter in die es ins wasser ein und
dadurch
hat man eine geringere verzögerung
energie lässt als bei der landung und
deswegen nimmt man auch gerne die
wasserlandung auch wenn sie sonst
natürlich später wenn wir sehen es ist
schwierig die kapsel dann aus dem wasser
zu fischen das dauert einfach seine zeit
aber das hat eben bei der landung ein
großer vorteil für die aus den autos ist
einfach weicher als gelaunt land ich
habe noch eine schlange
bitten entschuldigung ja das ist
natürlich ein effekt den der auch die
astronauten lieben dass sie etwas
sanfter landen als bei anderen bailando
bei dem nasa live stream soll es gerade
einen communication blackout geben soll
uns das sorgen machen wie würden sie das
einschätzen
der kommunikation blackout ist was was
erwartet ist das ist wir haben heuer
schon geschrieben jedoch nicht geschehen
wir haben sehr hart miteinander
gesprochen
es ist ja unheimlich was da an energie
abgebaut werden muss der sabbat hat
schon von den 28.000 km/h gesprochen die
die kapsel auf ihrer umlaufbahn hat und
diese riesige geschwindigkeit
unvorstellbarer geschwindigkeit muss ja
auf null runter gebremst werden und das
passiert jetzt im moment also durch die
erdatmosphäre daher nehmen wir uns die
erdatmosphäre zu hilfe es ist also nicht
irgendwelche raketentriebwerke die
abbremsen sondern eher atmosphäre bremst
uns hier habt und dadurch entsteht eine
enorme hitze und diese hitze führt dazu
dass die atmosphäre um die kapsel ist
sich in einem plasma verwandelt plasma
ist ein aggregatszustand wo von den atom
rümpfen die elektronen getrennt werden
plasma ist was leitfähiges und alles was
leitfähiges macht mit mit radiowellen
probleme das heißt wegen diesen plasma
was um die kapsel wegen der riesigen
hitze entsteht kann man mit der kapsel
nicht mehr kommunizieren und das ist
dieser blackout den wir jetzt erwarten
und der in etwa sechs minuten andauern
wird und das natürlich sehr spannende
und eine kritische phase während der
müssen ja man kann dann eben nicht mit
dem raumfahrzeug kommunizieren so wohl
nicht mit den astronauten als auch man
kann keine daten von den subsystemen
empfangen und zum beispiel auch nicht
von außen feststellen ob die kapsel in
der richtigen lage noch ist und ob sie
auf dem richtigen flug pfad ist das muss
die kapsel dann in der zeit selber
steuern die hat natürlich diese
ausstattung dass sie das alles selber
machen kann dafür ist gesorgt aber man
will ja am boden eigentlich immer up to
date sein und wissen was gerade läuft
und das ist eben in diesen sechs minuten
nicht möglich das ist eben dann der
crash der spannende teil daran dass man
eben nach sechs minuten wieder darauf
wartet dass die funkwellen wieder durch
das plasma durchkommen sobald es dünner
wird das heißt die die abbremst
geschwindigkeit die die wird geringer
dadurch wird das plasma natürlich auch
die dichte des plasmas geringer und
irgendwann schaffen es die funkwellen
wieder durch das geringere dichte des
plasmas hindurch und können wieder
empfangen werden und dann kann man
wieder neue daten empfangen und
natürlich man kann auch wieder mit den
astronauten reden das ist aber dann
schon zeitpunkt der kurz vor dem
entfalten des ersten kleinen fallschirms
liegt der die kapsel dann für den
weiteren abstieg stabilisiert und auch
abbremst
das ist alles ganz normal wir können
auch gerade mal vielleicht in den nasa
kontrollraum oder in den nasa livestream
schalten wieder also schauen einmal
einfach mal reinschauen wie das aussieht
genannt jetzt sehen wir es hier neben
mir also dass dieser große kontrollraum
und wir haben ja aber noch zeit also
noch rund 11 minuten so lange starren
die dort auch jetzt auf ihre bildschirme
und wir sprechen auch gleich noch mal
weiter in oberpfaffenhofen und können
auch jetzt gleich noch mal weiter über
die rückreise von matthias maurer
sprechen aber lasst uns gemeinsam erst
noch mal schauen was er überhaupt
gemacht hat ein halbes jahr lang dort im
all auf der iss einen beitrag von sarah
alaska
zu hause in 400 kilometern höhe sechs
monate war das hier matthias maurers
wohnung sein arbeitsplatz leben und
arbeiten in einer internationalen wg
mehr als 150 experimente führte maurer
mit seinem team durch eins davon beton
mischen für nachhaltiges bauen auf der
erde wir können hier erkenntnisse
gewinnen die uns dann helfen den beton
prozess auf dem boden zu optimieren und
wenn uns das gelingt dann können wir
hoffentlich auch unsere klimaziele in
stückchen besser erfüllen wie verhält
sich wasser in der schwerelosigkeit und
bio pflaster aus dem 3d drucker
hergestellt aus hautzellen auch das wan
teile von maurers forschung
außenbordeinsatz sieben stunden lang
wartungsarbeiten draußen an der
raumstation für maurer der höhepunkt
seiner mission die sein blick auf die
erde verändert hat schwebel jeden tag
mehrere mal in die cola und schauer
unter einfach unser blick so
faszinierend ist und ich bin einfach da
verliebten unseren wunderschönen
planeten
seine experimente seien cosmic bis nach
einem halben jahr ist schluss aber
seinen weltraum traum lebt weiter sagt
er
über diese mission von matthias maurer
und seine ankunft noch heute am späten
abend in deutschland können wir jetzt
sprechen mit meiner kollegin susanne
freitag die immer wieder über die
mission berichtet hat live in köln und
sie ist dort gemeinsam mit volker schmid
dem missionsleiter schönen guten morgen
ja schönen guten morgen ich stehe hier
mit einer maske weil wir hier im
medizinischen zentrum für
raumfahrtmedizin sind hier kommt
matthias maurer heute abend an wenn er
gelandet ist wir haben ja gerade schon
gehört das ist eine echte tortur für den
körper und er braucht eigentlich eine
richtige reha wenn er wieder zurückkommt
und deswegen wird er hier sozusagen
angeliefert die sind jede menge ärzte
aber auch andere patienten deswegen
trage ich auch eine maske und volker
schmid der hier bei mir steht ist der
mission manager das heißt er hat einen
totalen überblick über all die
experimente über die gesamte planung und
kann uns da sicherlich einiges dazu
sagen volker können sie uns sagen
mission accomplished hat alles super
geklappt ja so aus heutiger sicht
absolut ja und wir freuen uns natürlich
dass jetzt auch der abstieg und die
dann hoffentlich die wasserung gut
funktioniert und dann wird matthias
heute abend hier zurückerwartet und hier
dann erstmal ja seine erste phase der
rekonvaleszenz verbringen das heißt er
hat so eine art reha was das wetter
alles gemacht wenn er jetzt hier hierher
kommt nach diesen 3g dreimal das eigene
körpergewicht was man da so mit krieg in
welchem zustand kommt in so ein
astronaut zurück eigentlich das ist
immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich das
hängt von vom menschen ab kann man sagen
so ein halbes jahr in der
schwerelosigkeit ist natürlich
jetzt erst mal wieder völlig ungewohnt
wenn man dann schwerkraft sieht und der
körper muss sich wieder anpassen und
deswegen wird er hier auch erstmal dann
die 14 tage quasi hier wohnen in
anführungszeichen
untersuchungen werden hier gemacht hier
hier laufen auch normalerweise bettruhe
studie also das nvi habe hier in im
bereich der flug medizin im dlr ist hier
für alle eventualitäten ausgerüstet und
man kann sagen matthias hat hier eine
wohnung wenn es ihm gut geht dann wird
er ist einmal ein zwei tagen auch wieder
zu hause schlafen können aber wird jeden
tag hier untersucht das ganze reihe also
alles was man sich vorstellen kann wird
untersucht blutuntersuchung
kreislauf weil der körper muss ich ja
wieder einstellen das
gleichgewichtsorgan muss ich wieder
adaptieren an die schwerkraft so nach
einem halben jahr und das ist in der tat
bei jedem menschen komplett
unterschiedlich wir haben
sie hatten gesagt dass es so tests gab
bei astronauten die dann in bei ihrer
rückkehr erst mal vom hockern springen
mussten um zu gucken ob die überhaupt
noch gerade stehen können willst du was
da auf stattfinden das wird eigentlich
meistens direkt nach der landung schon
gemacht also sowas zum zumindest bei so
hughes da hat man die kosmonauten
astronauten zelt gebracht und kurz nach
der landung er eben erste sogenannte
basis daten erhoben also gleichgewicht
kreislauf solche sachen und da musste
ist eine übung von von einer erhöhung
auf den boden springen und gucken wie
wie der mensch reagiert so das ist eine
eine der übung und dieses dieses
sogenannte baseline data collection die
läuft immer nach dem gleichen protokoll
ab und das wird jetzt sicherlich ein
land dann gemacht oder auf dem schiff
dann auch gemacht wenn die aus der
kapsel raus sind und dann muss man auch
erst mal ein paar minuten ruhigen auf
jeden fall weil so ein wiedereintritt
haben wir ja gehört ist auch eine tortur
kräfte wirken also und das muss der
körper alles ab können
würde kurz unterbrechen weil wir haben
fragen im stream und zwar von ina könig
bei facebook hier möchte gerne von herrn
schmid wissen an was für experimenten
wurde oben denn genau gearbeitet
also wir haben eigentlich eine summe von
experimenten gehabt der schwerpunkt war
materialwissenschaften wir haben roman
physiologie gehabt es ist ja ein beitrag
schon erwähnt worden der beton war ein
eines der wichtigsten experimente
nachhaltiger beton und dann auch die
produktionsprozesse verändern wir haben
mit halsschmerzen gehabt zb ein
sogenanntes elektro blech regierung mit
der man bessere transformatoren in
zukunft bauen können wird effizienter
transformatoren hoffentlich wir haben
ganz ganz viel
technologie demonstration gehabt das
pflaster wurde erwähnt bio printer also
da versucht man künstliche haut als als
pflaster als wundverband zu testen
das war jetzt zum allerersten mal da
dann haben wir eine ms anzug gehabt dass
es elektronische muskelstimulation
damit kann eigentlich ja über
praktische vibrations- kissen der körper
und die muskeln stimuliert werden die
schwerelosigkeit bauen sich ja musste
und noch masse mich ab wenn man ja quasi
nicht trainiert und
man muss eben zweieinhalb stunden etwa
pro tag trainieren und wenn man dadurch
mit dieser muskel stimulation auf
elektronische art und weise weniger
sport treiben muss dann kommt das wieder
der wissenschaft zu gute weil der anzug
kann natürlich beim arbeiten getragen
werden und das ist der vorteil dabei
also ganz ganz viel
den strahlungs experimente von den über
100 experimenten waren etwa 60 aus
europa 34 deutsche und das ist also ein
ganz drei das programm was da immer auch
die beide gestellt wird und wir haben
auch gleich noch mehr zeit natürlich mit
beiden in köln darüber zu sprechen was
genau bei der mission passiert ist aber
jetzt sehen wir gerade im nasa livebild
dass er sich etwas tut wir sehen hier
ein leuchten im all und ich kann es
natürlich nicht so gut einschätzen wie
unsere beiden experten in
oberpfaffenhofen wo wir jetzt noch mal
nachfragen können was wir denn da gerade
sehen und was da jetzt gerade passiert
so wir sind zurück in oberpfaffenhofen
und ich sehe auch sie schauen gebannt
auf das live-bild der nasa können sie
uns erklären was wir da denn gerade
sehen
das leuchtende objekt macht leuchtende
augen bei uns genau das heißt zum einen
der blackout ist gut überstanden die
kapseln er sich dem zeitpunkt jetzt
genau jetzt ist der entscheidende
zeitpunkt dass man dass die ersten
kleinen zwei jobs wie die heißen renz
fallschirme ausgefahren werden heraus
geschossen werden die stabilisieren die
kapsel und bremsen sie auch ab und zwar
auf eine geschwindigkeit damit dann die
großen fallschirm mit dem man am schluss
beim wasser sieht
da sehen wir die maxime
und können jetzt auch
oder mit ober fallschirm ist heute von
abba zieht auch ein bisschen wie sie in
wind- oder in der strömung sich bewegen
und sie die sind jetzt die erste stufe
des fallschirm und jetzt
bekommt schon die zweite stufe zu sehen
jetzt haben die zwei kleine fallschirme
die vier großen fallschirm aus dem eine
füllung rausgezogen die werden jetzt
schrittweise geöffnet man macht es eben
nicht in einem schritt sonst werden die
lasten zu groß und
öffnet langsam in drei schritten die
fallschirme bis zur vollen hoffnung
hervorgehen vorbei und juni
voll an den vier fallschirmen hängen wir
haben eine frage bei youtube dazu und
zwar mit welcher geschwindigkeit gleitet
die kapsel an den fallschirm zur erde
so circa 20 bis 25 stundenkilometer ist
die aufprallgeschwindigkeit oder die
endgeschwindigkeit bevor sie auf das
wasser auf setzt es gibt zwei
verschiedene fallschirme wieder dieser
schon gesagt hat die bei verschiedenen
geschwindigkeiten auch machen die
kleinen bei relativ hohen
geschwindigkeiten 500 km h glaube ich
und dann bremsen die großen fallschirm
ab bis zu 20 25 km/h konstant ins wasser
fällt noch eine schnelligkeit wird eben
dadurch abgebaut indem es ins wasser
eintaucht und daneben auf diese ein bis
zwei meter die sie 20 stundenkilometer
auf null abgebremst wird noch eine frage
von calvin klein hinter youtube
natürlich hoffen wir dass alle nicht
aber er fragt was könnte denn im
schlimmsten fall schief gehen was wir
alle natürlich nicht hoffen
nicht also wenn die vier fallschirme
entfaltet sind dann haben wir den
kritischen ressourcen teilen überstanden
die kapsel ist jetzt noch vielleicht
1000 meter hoch und schwebt langsam
machte er die entgegen der letzte
kritische punkt ist eigentlich ob sich
die vier fallschirme enthalten das haben
sie schon getan hat es gesehen das hat
alles geklappt es ist auch eine reserve
eingebaut das eben ein fallschirm sich
nicht entfaltet werde auch alles okay
ist sobald wir vor 50 jahren bei apollo
15 passiert die haben drei fallschirme
da haben sich nur zwei geöffnet da ist
auch die landung völlig normal gelaufen
man baut eben da reserven 1 damit man
eben auch im falle einer kleinen störung
noch die crew sicher zur erde
zurückbringen
jetzt nach sechs sekunden sagt unser
countdown also mal gucken ob das stimmt
ob wir das dann auch wirklich gleich
sehen können meinen sie wir können das
dann sehen wirklich wie wie das auf dem
wasser landet es ja schon ziemlich
dunkel
ja was sollte schon sehen aber es mit
danach natürlich ist natürlich jetzt
nicht das beste für die bilder aber
würde man es vielleicht auch daran
erkennen dass die
der entscheidende punkt also wo man es
erkennt ist also wenn man so wie die
kapsel jetzt nicht sehen würde wenn sich
das wasser spritzt weil es so dunkel ist
die fallschirme fallen dann in sich
zusammen weil sie eben von unten keinen
zug mehr durch die kapsel haben werden
dieses kollabieren die und fallender
auf die wasseroberfläche und freuten
sich zusammen und das ist das
entscheidende zeichen dass das beendet
ist der abstieg jetzt gerade schon so
langsam und gemütlich also diese
fallschirms regeln aber täuscht das ist
das gerade noch wahnsinnig schnell wie
schnell ist das was wir gerade sehen
wie vorhergesagt habe 20 25
stundenkilometer was natürlich dann noch
dazukommt ist ein bisschen
windgeschwindigkeit weil die falsche
mehr da sind keine
steuerungsmöglichkeit haben sondern wie
sind mit der geschwindigkeit jetzt ist
das was ich gesagt habe sobald die
kapsel auf wasser auftritt
falten sich die falsche mit zusammen
weil diese kraft die gewichtskraft oder
kapsel weg ist und man sieht jetzt
langsam ging falsch ermitteln auf die
wasseroberfläche und jetzt kann man
wirklich erfreut sein dass matthias
maurer und seine drei kolleginnen und
kollegen gut auf der erde angekommen
sind und tolle sache sechs monate
mission erfolgreich beendet und wir
freuen uns dass wir sie wieder zurück
haben auf mutter erde das könnte man
wirklich gut erkennen werten recht aber
das sei ja wirklich nach der perfekten
landung aus oder
wichtig das ist eine super landung die
kapsel ist ja auch sehr schön zu sehen
ich vermute dass es wohl infrarotbild
und die kapsel ist ja sehr erwartung
dürfte wieder ein dritten aber gesagt
sie die atmosphäre über 2000 grad heiß
oder sitze schritt auch der rest der
kapsel ist natürlich auch entsprechend
etwas wärmer nicht so warm und das kann
man natürlich dann eben sehr viel zu
erkennen und jetzt erwarten wir als
nächstes das ein oder zwei kleine boote
auf die kapsel zu fahren die noch ein
paar so security checks machen und dann
wird die kapsel von
dem schiff aufgenommen dass sich dann in
bewegung setzt und dann wegen soweit die
kapsel abenden schiff angekommen ist
können die astronauten dann auch
aussteigen aber das wird sich ja doch
eine halbe stunde dauern und solange
natürlich diese halbe stunde noch dauert
wir wollen natürlich auch dabei sein
wenn sich die kapsel öffnet können wir
aber ja auch noch mal über die mission
sprechen und sie waren ja auch daran
beteiligt also in den letzten sechs
monaten können sie uns noch mal erklären
was genau ihre rolle war hier auf der
erde
ja wir eben oberpfaffenhofen sind dafür
zuständig dass wir das columbus modul im
am laufen halten des columbus modul ist
in erster linie ein experimentallabor
das heißt der arbeitsplatz für matthias
maurer und seine kollegen dort sind
viele experimente untergebracht die eben
dazu dienen in mikrogravitation
auszunutzen und eben für verschiedene
experimente zu nutzen der matthias
maurer hat uns da in sehr vielen fällen
sehr gut geholfen eine sehr interessante
sache war das eine pumpe in einem
nutzlast schrank der metalle auf
schmilzt und zwar im vakuum unten der
schwebe
ausgefallen ist und die pumpe war ich
gar nicht dafür gedacht dass sie
ausgetauscht werden sollte und trotzdem
noch hat sich matthias maurer das
ersatzteil eben mitgebracht und es wurde
geliefert und er hat dann in einer
siebenstündigen aktion diese pumpe
ausgetauscht und das experiment kann
jetzt wieder fortgeführt werden also das
sind so
highlights seiner mission die eben
besondere fähigkeiten feinmechanik und
auch training natürlich erfordert damit
man solche sachen
arbeiten die nicht geplant sind trotzdem
durchführen kann und
das daneben hat er natürlich viele
experimente durchgeführt zum einen
experimente die auch für die ausbildung
als schüler zum beispiel interessant
sind aber natürlich auch experimente die
die wissenschaft voranbringen und die
nicht nur im columbus labor sondern
natürlich auch auf anderen stellen auf
der iss gemacht wurden und ein highlight
seiner auf wenn sein aufenthalts an bord
war natürlich der ausstieg aus der ss am
23 märz als er unter anderem einige
kabel gesteckt hat die noch gefehlt
haben um die bartholomäer plattform an
außen an columbus in betrieb zu nehmen
und jetzt kann für diese plattform dient
dazu weitere ausnutzen lassen zu
betreiben
die können jetzt ab anfang nächsten
jahres dann geliefert werden und dort
ihre experimente im freien weltraum und
dadurch für das ist das war einer seiner
highlights auf ihn persönlich natürlich
ist so eine wie immer eine besondere
sache die noch mal heraus sticht aus der
sechsmonatigen aufenthalt an bord wir
können über die mission jetzt natürlich
auch nochmal mit dem missionsleiter in
köln sprechen wir kommen aber auch noch
mal zu ihnen zurück nach
oberpfaffenhofen danke für den moment
und schalten jetzt noch mal nach köln zu
meiner kollegin susanne freitag und zu
herrn schmid dem missionsleiter volker
schmid denn wir haben es gerade gehabt
von also jetzt im letzten halben jahr
und von den experimenten die also
matthias maurer durchgeführt hat und ich
habe eine frage bei facebook von isaac
und zwar geht es jetzt da erstmal noch
um seine rückkehr und zwar verändert
sich eigentlich der geschmackssinn kann
eigentlich sofort auf der erde wieder
normal gegessen werden das können sie
bestimmt beantworten herr schmid denn
matthias maurer kommt ja zu ihnen dann
jetzt im laufe des tages natürlich in
mehreren stunden und wird auch einige
zeit bei ihnen noch bleiben richtig
das stimmt der wird also hier erstmal
für zwei wochen untersucht und auf jeden
fall wird er ein zwei tage hier auf am
ende hab wirklich auch wohnen das hängt
immer von der verfassung ab jetzt zur
frage der geschmackssinn in der regel
ändert sich das ein bisschen da oben in
der schwerelosigkeit und man der körper
braucht eine zeit dass er sich wieder an
passt an die an die erdrotation also an
eingehe so zu sagen und das ist
natürlich bei jedem menschen auch wieder
anders also aber dass das sollte in den
nächsten tagen wieder normal werden und
interessant ist wenn die die kosmonauten
astronauten zurückkehren wenn die lupe
aufgeht die ersten eindrücke die die
gerüche
und von vom mehr von oder vom land je
nachdem die sind sehr intensiv also und
da fängt eigentlich der
anpassungsprozess schon anja also da
muss man ein paar tage zu geben und dann
bis ich das alles normalisiert und wenn
wir jetzt noch mal auf diese lange zeit
diesen missionen scheint genau susanne
ich wollte gerade bei dir nachfragen du
hast nämlich jede mission von matthias
maurer seit anbeginn begleitet du warst
auch am anfang dann mit in den usa als
dann auch der staat erst mal um eine
ganze woche verschoben wurde richtig
richtig und am ende wir waren gemeinsam
in den in den usa und haben gewartet und
am ende hat es so lange gedauert das
tier form statt zurückfahren mussten das
war vor allen dingen auch für die
wissenschaftler natürlich sehr
frustrierend denn ich war jetzt gerade
dabei als der splash doch statt wir
gucken hier natürlich auch nasa tv und
der volker schmidt hat als erstes mal
111 ii gemacht weil natürlich in diesen
sechs monaten das sind hunderte
wissenschaftler auf der erde mit diesen
experimenten gefasster werden finden
direkte schalten stadt von der iss zu
den leuten lieder diese experimente mit
betreuen und dahin so viel herzblut dran
auch wissenschaftler herzblut was ist
das denn jetzt so fühle ich frag einfach
auch mal volker schmid wenn man sieht es
hat jetzt geklappt es ist vorbei ist man
da ein bisschen stolz ja absolut das ist
jetzt mission accomplished quasi das ist
die letzte phase der demission wenn
matthias dann heute abend hier zurück
ist dann können wir quasi denn den
grünen haken dran machen dann kommt die
post mission phase und dann haben wir
eigentlich auch mit den wissenschaftlern
die werden dann aus einige experimente
laufen auch noch weiter das sind viele
kampagnen
teil wird von samantha cristoforetti
weitergeführt aber für matthias beginnt
jetzt die post mission er kann jetzt
rekonvaleszenz machen wer kann sich
erholen und dann werden wir
später mit ihm auch in die idee
briefings gehen in die wissenschaft in
den missionen um zu gucken will was es
wie gelaufen aber erst mal grund nicht
atmen wir sind froh ja
lassen sie uns gleich nochmal zum die
briefing und natürlich auch wie es ihnen
jetzt einen geht gehen aber können sie
uns gerade noch mal kurz das live-bild
der nasa beschreiben was sie ja auch
sehen weil wir können jetzt gerade in
die kapsel schauen und werden auch eben
ein paar boote schon ankommen sehen was
passiert ja jetzt gerade
genau also jetzt sieht man die kapsel
die die monitore zwei helme das sind ist
wahrscheinlich hier platz eins und zwei
sozusagen pilot und kommandant
die kapsel die boote
die das opfer schließlich gesagt hat die
stabilisieren jetzt erstmal die kapsel
und machen 6 treten keine rest
treibstoffe aus zum beispiel
ist die kapsel stabil im wasser und man
muss auch bedenken dass die kapsel
aufgeheizt ist durch den
flug durch die atmosphäre durch die
luft reibung aufgeheizt und man gibt
jetzt einfach ein bisschen zeit zur
abkühlung noch und in der zeit werden
natürlich wird natürlich geprüft ob
nicht irgendwo durch einen noch
klemmendes ventil rest treibstoffe
austreten oder so kann immer mal
passieren aber ist jetzt hier
offensichtlich nicht der fall und ja für
die gros ist es jetzt quasi erst mal
auch ein bisschen verschlafen
ruhephase
kommunikation wird stattfinden zwischen
dem bergungsteam und unter besatzung an
bord wie gesagt das ist alles
vollautomatisch gewesen in dem rückflug
und da kann man die die crews sind jetzt
ist oder ist sind passagiere quasi sie
können eingreifen während des rückfluges
müssen aber nicht und jetzt wird
gewartet eben bis das bergungsteam vor
ort ist und dann jetzt weiter jetzt
sehen wir gerade aber auch schon erste
pro jahr hier sieht man jetzt
genau genau die gucken jetzt wie gesagt
ist da alles im grünen bereich
und ja das wird jetzt noch ein bisschen
dauern
bis die kapsel an geborgen werden kann
da kommt ein größeres schiff dann
wie gesagt die prüfen jetzt
[Musik]
treibstoffe rest treibstoffe irgendwo
aber das scheint nicht der fall zu sein
so wie es aussieht
zum ersten mal dass ein deutscher
astronaut im wasser landet nur das hat
es noch nie gegeben bei zeitz basics
jetzt dabei ist landen die in florida
erstens verschiebt sich vielmehr glaube
ich und zweitens ist das jetzt ja
wirklich eine ganz neue erfahrung dass
er sind sie wahrscheinlich auch gespannt
ja ganz genau das ist wirklich die erste
reale wasserung ich meine im notfall
training
sowohl in china und in russland mit mit
den sojus kapsel oder kapseln wird
notwasserung auch trainiert aber das
jetzt hier ist sozusagen die erste
fassung eines deutschen
absolut wenn sie waren noch dabei
geradezu eine schreiben und einer
entschuldigung wir reden uns hier so ein
bisschen dazwischen weil wir eine kleine
verzögerung haben ich wollte ihn nur
noch mal aufgreifen herr schmidt sie
waren ja auch dabei eigentlich zu
beschreiben wie erleichtert sie jetzt
sind da hatte ich dann unterbrochen als
ich die ihre boote kommen sie
ja also ich bin jetzt erstmal froh dass
für matthias diese reise erfolgreich zu
ende gegangen ist dass er gesund
gelandet ist weil diese dieser rückflug
durch die atmosphäre das ist schon auch
noch mal eine belastung drei bis
vierfach das körpergewicht wird da in
der in der heißen phase sozusagen zu
ertragen sein oder muss müssen die ab
können die astronauten und das wird
natürlich trainiert in zentrifugen aber
wir sind erstmal froh für uns geht jetzt
so ein halbes jahr mission mit einer
erfolgreichen wasserung zu ende und das
macht uns sehr sehr froh erst mal und
vor allen dingen auch die experimente so
gut geklappt haben wir haben echt super
programm gehabt
ich höre gerade auf mein ohr dass wir
jetzt auch gerade noch mal bilder haben
in die wir reinschauen können von der
landung gemeinsam und wir werden auch
noch mal über die mission sprechen und
schauen wir erst mal gemeinsam in die
bäder moments
und sie gern
[Applaus]
zurück ins zentrum ins deutsche zentrum
für luft und raumfahrt nach
oberpfaffenhofen
ich habe fragen an sie beide herr sabbat
und herrlich und zwar bei uns aus dem
stream fragt schwarze bei youtube 9
werden die fallschirme nach der
wasserung von der kapsel abgetrennt weil
wir konnten sie jetzt ja natürlich gar
nicht mehr sehen da im wasser
zurück ja ein ganz wichtiges manöver die
fallschirme werden sofort nach der
landung von der kapsel abgetrennt
es schaut jetzt nach dem sehr guten
wetter aus aber sollte der wind da sein
dann ist das wirklich eine heß situation
dass der wind die fallschirme dem
aufbläst und die kapsel wieder verzieht
es ist tatsächlich eine der wenigen
schalter die wirklich in der kapsel
physikalischen auch da sind dass man im
notfall die kapsel die fallschirme auch
aufmachen kann wenn die automatische
korrektur versagt und eines der beiden
rettungsschiffe was wir als erstes
gesehen haben hat dann auch die aufgabe
diese falsche mit zu bergen und jetzt
war es wirklich so dass 24 stunden lang
so lang hat ja ungefähr die reise
gedauert man wirklich in diesem sitzen
sitzt wie wir es jetzt auch gerade sehen
können man sich nicht bewegen kann außer
wenn die arme das ist schon 24 stunden
einfach komplettes still sitzen oder
nein also die können sich in der zeit
diese zehn stunden in der reinen orbit
phase wo keine manöver stattgefunden
haben könnten sich als den sitzen schon
raus bewegen die kapsel ist ja etwas
größer als die sojus kapseln die bietet
auch etwas freiraum um sich mal
außerhalb besitzt aufzuhalten natürlich
ist es eine kapsel und damit vom raum
her beschränkt dann muss man sich schon
wirklich alles sehr eng vorstellen und
das sind mehr als vier sitze in einem
auto in dem er sich eben dann 24 stunden
aufhalten besser ist es sicher nicht
aufmachen das ist der unterschied darauf
wird jetzt sehnsüchtig gewartet und was
wird was würden sie aber jetzt
einschätzen was muss alles jetzt
passieren bis also die türen aufgehen
warum quasi dauert das jetzt noch mal
eine gute halbe stunde
ja die die vorgehensweise
bei dieser landung ist ebenso dass die
kapsel zuerst auf das schiff gehoben
wird und dann die astronauten aussteigen
können manche werden sich noch an apollo
erinnern da wurde das anders gemacht da
wurden die astronauten in ein
schlauchboot über geführt und das
schlauchboot dann vom schlauchboot aus
mit hubschrauber dann auf dem schiff
gebracht das ganze ist natürlich noch
aufwändiger und man hat sich dann eben
hier entschieden das lieber die
astronauten ein paar minuten länger in
der kapsel zu lassen wenn es keinen
keine probleme gibt dann werden sie
einfach mit einem kran
wird die kapsel dann auf das schiff
gehoben und wenn die kapsel dort fest
verankert ist öffnet war die die lupe
und die astronauten werden auch ein
anderer raus geholt und auf eine liege
gebracht das wird man nachher vermutlich
auch noch sehen und dann in einen in
räume gebracht wo sie sich dann etwas
von dem flug erholen können und das ist
der der standardprozess bei den spacex
landungen und hat natürlich einige
vorteile gegenüber den apollo approach
auch wenn man die astronauten dann nicht
gleich sozusagen fünf minuten nach der
landung sieht man weiß ja über die
kommunikationskanäle dass es ihnen gut
geht und wie man ja schon gesagt haben
sie sitzen jetzt 24 stunden in dieser
kapsel dann ist diese halbe stunde
länger auch keine große aufgabe mehr
dafür kann man sie eben auf dem schiff
viel einfacher aus der kapsel rausholen
und ist auch für die astronauten
angenehmer diese
dieses aussteigen aus der kapsel als auf
dem wackeligen wasser man sieht ja die
kapsel hinter uns wenn man sie immer
noch sieht man momentan sieht man die
ihnen das innere der caps laden hat ja
gesehen die kapsel wackelt der ich im
wasser doch stark und da ist es viel
angenehmer an auf einem deutlich
stabileren schiff dann aus der kapsel
auszusteigen es gibt noch eine nachfrage
bei facebook von sich er fragt sich ob
der rechts in der kapsel geschlafen hat
es hätte so ausgesehen ist da schlafen
schlafen überhaupt zu denken
es kommt auf den einzelnen darauf an
dass ich habe gesehen dass mattias mario
hatte die augen zu der wird sich einfach
auf die jeden flug konzentriert haben er
ist ja jetzt nur ein passagier in dem
fall die beiden der pilot oder commander
sitzen in der mitte die mir jetzt auf
dem bild links und rechts die helme
sieht dies sind die verantwortlichen
flug wobei der flug auch im großen teil
automatisch abläuft die haben mehr oder
weniger überwachungsfunktion und wie
vorher schon vom turm gesagt wurde es
gibt einen knopf einen zum beispiel ein
paar wichtige knöpfe aber einer davon
ist eben das absprengen der fallschirme
falls ist nicht automatisch funktioniert
dafür sind die dann verantwortlich es
gibt sicher noch einige andere aufgaben
und aber damit dass maurer ist in dem
fall nur der passagier und hat sich
einfach ruhig auf diesen wiedereintritt
vorbereitet und wir warten jetzt
natürlich noch gemeinsam gespannt auf
die dieses rauskommen auf der kapsel und
sprechen dann natürlich auch wieder
darüber aber es gibt natürlich noch
andere spannende themen die wir jetzt in
diesem ganzen raumfahrt kosmos
ansprechen können denn auf der
internationalen raumstation iss das ist
auch nicht ganz uninteressant arbeiten
europäer amerikaner russen alle
gemeinsam zusammen und natürlich wenn
man jetzt das stichwort russland hört
fragt man sich auch wie gut funktioniert
die zusammenarbeit noch und mein kollege
pablo sinaloa hier hat einen beitrag
dazu vorbereitet indem er kurz gemeinsam
reinschauen können
die internationale raumstation iss
außenposten der menschheit im all ein
wunder der technik und fast noch mehr
ein wunder internationaler
zusammenarbeit nach jahrzehnten des
wettrüstens im all während des kalten
kriegs das zeigt auch die
zusammensetzung der jüngsten besatzung
zwei russen drei amerikaner und mit
matthias maurer ein deutscher doch am 24
februar hat russland einen neuen krieg
begonnen das hat auswirkungen bis ins
all moskaus raumfahrt chef drohte damit
die iss abstürzen zu lassen postete
dieses video auf telegramm russische
kosmonauten fliegen zurück zur erde und
lassen den amerikanischen kollegen oben
dann stürzt die iss ab ein scherz sei
das hieß es später die europäische
raumfahrtorganisation esa reagiert
verschärfter dargestellt aber natürlich
wir nehmen das ernst und der westliche
teil wenn ich ihn so nennen kann
verlässlich auf russland um die station
wieder zu anzuheben und in den richtigen
ort verbringen weil die station ja im
lauf der monate leicht ab sinkt die iss
bislang ein erfolgsmodell
internationaler zusammenarbeit
zum ersten mal ist nun durch einen krieg
auf der erde auch die zukunft der
kooperation im all insgesamt ernsthaft
gefährdet
meine kollegin susanne freitag berichtet
seit beginn der mission von matthias
maurer über dieses projekt susanne wie
würdest du das einordnen jetzt gerade in
anbetracht natürlich der situation hier
bei uns auf der erde dem krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine ist kann man da eben
sich jetzt noch verlässlich darauf
verlässlich darauf verlassen dass die
zusammenarbeit da oben im all arbeiten
gut funktioniert
also ich denke auf der iss ist es im
moment so dass die zusammenarbeit
tatsächlich gut funktioniert das sagen
alle zumindest alle die schon mal im all
waren wir haben letztens mit dem
französischen astronauten thomas piske
darüber gesprochen aber die insgesamt
ist das ein riesen schlag für die
raumfahrt also es ist zum aller ersten
mal ist die raumfahrt thema in einem
politischen konflikt das hat es vorher
nie gegeben das war eigentlich immer
übergeordnet man hat nie das war nie
davon beeinflusst jetzt kommen aus
russland wirklich starke provokationen
und es gibt auch erste konsequenzen also
die esa hat sich aus mehreren projekten
zurückgezogen eine mission jetzt die
mars analysen machen sollte exomars die
im september starten sollte ist jetzt
erst mal abgesagt worden und es gibt
auch mond projekte die gemeinsam geplant
waren wo russische anteile bei diesen
missionen mit dabei waren die jetzt
einfach nicht stattfinden können das hat
sehr sehr gravierende konsequenzen in
den nächsten zehn bis 15 jahren und man
kann schon sagen dass der raumfahrt mit
diesen krieg auch einen schlag versetzt
wurde wir hatten wenig möglichkeiten zu
kommunizieren das wird sehr bedeckt
gehalten weil man auch die astronauten
vor der russischen propaganda schützen
möchte und der der esa chef hat sich
dazu geäußert hat gesagt wir müssen
jetzt gucken dass wir insgesamt
versuchen unabhängiger zu werden von
russischen material von russischen
technologien aber das ist natürlich eine
schwierige sache um jetzt noch mal auf
diese bedrohung zurückzukommen von dem
roskosmos chef der sagt wir lassen jetzt
die iss abstürzen da kriegt man
natürlich erst mal schräg und denkt 'die
fallen dann alle runter so einfach ist
es nicht dazu kam volker schmid einiges
sagen
es ist ja ein kooperationsprojekt wenn
man sich jetzt mal die iss nimmt kann
roskosmos die es überhaupt abstürzen
lassen technisch ist das möglich so
einfach ist es nicht also das ist ja
verbund an kontrollzentrum wussten
moskau wie gesagt dann die europäische
das europäische kontrollzentrum in
oberpfaffenhofen
japan auch eben für ihre module es ist
so dass die die russischen kollegen eben
mit ihren modulen die die bahn erhebungs
kapazität vornehmen können durch kleine
düsen und auch durch progress durch
angedockte progress frachter so die
station verliert durch den rest
widerstand der atmosphäre ebenso 50 bis
100 meter am tag je nach sonnenaktivität
auch und da muss also alle paar wochen
muss man einen bahn anhebung impuls
passieren damit die iss auf ihrer
nominellen flughöhe bleibt
es ist wohl in der tat so verzahnt
einerseits die russischen kollegen
machen die bahn an e-books kapazität auf
der anderen seite die amerikaner liefern
den strom also für die für die
regelkreise für die computer und
auch die russische module beziehen strom
sind also das ist das ist doch enger
verzahnt und man kann jetzt auch nicht
einfach ein modul abkoppeln oder so das
so einfach geht es nicht wenn es so sein
sollte dass das man da in zukunft
einschränkungen haben
wird dann muss man sich gedanken machen
technisch kann man das lösen aber
natürlich nicht sofort man muss erst mal
vielleicht ein wenig die wie so ein
zyklus raumfrachter dahingehend
modifizieren dass so eine bei anderen e
books kapazität dann vielleicht auch von
westlicher seite gewährleistet werden
kann also einfach ist es nicht in beide
richtungen nicht
würden sie uns noch mal ganz kurz hinter
ihnen passiert gerade wieder so von
außen gesehen um etwa entspannen wir uns
noch mal kurz beschreiben
da sieht es jetzt so aus ja die kapsel
ist jetzt gesichert und das
bergungsschiff ist in der nähe und
die die laien beziehungsweise kann dann
angebracht also das ist kurz vorm
rausziehen der kapsel kurz vor der
bergung quasi auf das schiff man sieht
da diesen diesen kreis das ist die
struktur wo die kapseln aufgesetzt wird
sozusagen weich gepolstert die kapsel
wird ja wieder verwendet werden und
deswegen muss man da sorgfalt walten
lassen man sieht da den den kran so
sagen die beiden träger daran für die
wird die dann auf heraus gehievt auch
aus dem wasser das dauert jetzt
sicherlich noch ein paar minuten wir
sind jetzt
bergungs schwimmer einer ist auf der
kapsel
dass das alles
perfekt läuft
alles sehr gut aus oster vorsicht walten
lassen die see ist ruhig das ist auch
wichtig das wetter und seegang spielen
immer eine sehr zentrale rolle bei der
ganzen sache und das ist extrem wichtig
dass das man da alle alle parameter
sozusagen
berücksichtigt sie haben es angesprochen
machen alles gleiche frage ja genau die
kapsel soll wieder verwendet werden denn
seine ressourcen 20 fliegen ihre
astronauten mit spacex meine ich vorher
waren ist glaube ich die russischen
sojus-kapseln warum ist man diese
verbindung dann irgendwann eingegangen
ja die europäer sind ja teil des so
genannten westlichen orbit segments der
iss und die aber es war nur eine frage
der zeit nach der außerdienststellung
vom space shuttle dass die amerikaner
wieder von eigenem boden aus staaten und
astronauten zur iss bringen das war von
vornherein klar und
insofern ist dann die westliche seite
also die europäer die japaner die
pflegen in zukunft oder flogen ab dem ab
dem zeitpunkt dann wieder mit den mit
den vorträgen kapseln von spacex es
kommen auch noch andere fahrzeuge is
boring starliner dream chaser da wird
also sicherlich noch einiges passieren
in der zukunft die kapseln die werden
wiederverwertet auch die ersten stufen
der der verein raketen das ist auch neu
sozusagen man will darum mehr
nachhaltigkeit und in der tat die
teuersten elemente sind die triebwerke
die treibstoff pumpen und da kann man
schon einiges auch auf bahn
man will er günstiger werden im
transport zur iss und zurück und das ist
ein element wie man so was erreichen
kann und natürlich lohnt sich das bei
höherer flug agents das ist ganz klar so
man muss so 10 12 flüge im jahr haben
damit sich so eine wiederverwendbarkeit
auch dann wirklich lohnt und das ist
hier ja gegeben bei
spacex ja und die kapseln übrigens auch
in russland die sojus kapseln werden
auch da werden auch teile wieder
verwendet werden geprüft und alles was
gut ist was funktioniert wird ausgebaut
und repariert und wieder eingebaut und
und hier ist das ähnlich also die die
schadhaften teile werden ausgewechselt
und dann werden die die kapseln überholt
und komplett aufgearbeitet und wieder
verwendet für neue flüge wir haben noch
ein paar ganz praktische fragen bei uns
im stream
susanne dort ist ja die möglichkeit in
matthias maurer auch zu interviewen er
auch vor seiner vor seinem einsatz von
einem halben jahr und marko völke bei
facebook fragt sich beim rückflug gelte
aber auch für den hinflug wird dann
gegessen getrunken wie funktioniert das
auch mit dem toilettengang muss man
windeln tragen hat matthias maurer da
verraten wie das funktioniert bei dieser
langen reise hin und zurück
also ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht
aber ich habe gehört dass astronauten
ihre windeln tragen weil es glaube ich
in dieser kapsel schwierig ist ja also
die können die haben natürlich ein
bisschen mehr platz wieder in einer
sojus kapsel
rund und auch früher bei apollo ist hier
die dies bei sixx schon ein bisschen
geräumiger sie können wenn die oben sind
nach dem start können die können die
aufstehen die könnten quasi ein bisschen
schweben die haben ein bisschen freiheit
das ist schon sehr sehr viel die können
essen und trinken
toilette muss ich sagen weil sie jetzt
gerade nicht aber die die russischen
kollegen also die die justiz die haben
eine toilette im hopital module und die
können sich da auch rein bewegen also
das muss auch gewährleistet sein weil 24
stunden transfer zur raumstation iss
eine ganze menge und auch beim rückflug
sowas muss gewährleistet sein
sie sagten die ist geräumiger da sein
und ich finde die mieter jetzt gerade
gar nicht so groß aus aber natürlich
wenn denn das kann jetzt auch täuschen
hier auf dem bildschirm aber das ist
jetzt wirklich alles natürlich was wir
da sehen so groß ist diese katze ja
genau genau das sind vier personen drin
und die ist schon also gegenüber anderen
kapseln
etwas geräumiger und hier sieht man auch
die spuren die so ein wiedereintritt
hinterlässt nur die rußspuren durch die
reibungshitze und ja wie gesagt das
sieht alles sehr sehr gut aussieht will
es gut gesichert und die wird jetzt
abgelassen auf das polster sozusagen
und ganz sanft abgesenkt und ja das ist
auch wieder ein ein sehr guter schritt
dann hin und
man sieht ja auch die lupe man sieht die
falsche hoffnungen man sieht unterhalb
der luke die die steuer triebwerke mit
denen die kapsel auch dann den den
wiedereintritt fazit ein bisschen noch
regulieren kann das haben wir gehört von
meinen kollegen aus oberpfaffenhofen
und ja jetzt wird die abgesetzt und das
ist auch gut wenn du das schaukeln auf
see auch wenn die see ruhig es ist
natürlich auch ein bisschen
herausfordernd für die
person im drin für die crew nach seinem
ritt durch die atmosphäre
da muss man schon auch einen guten magen
haben manchmal
ja
also hier ist jetzt gesichert
und sagen sie uns wird das wäre gesorgt
das ist ganz entschuldigung bitte
ja die erste fassung eines deutschen
astronauten auch erfolgreich
überstanden sozusagen wirklich ein
historischer moment das stimmt und jetzt
wird also als nächstes die lupe geöffnet
ist das jetzt aber auch noch mal ein
moment der dauert was passiert jetzt als
nächstes
jetzt sichert man die kapsel auf dem
schiff
und wie gesagt dann wird die öffnung
vorbereitet ich denke das wird es noch
ein bisschen dauern
bis die dann aufgemacht wird da werden
jetzt erst die line up gemacht die die
kapsel wird arretiert die wird gesichert
also dass das hebe geschirr ab gemacht
wahrscheinlich und
dann nimmt das schiff auf kurs richtung
tampa wo man dann den hafen eben
ansteuert und
ich denke wir wollen wir das braucht
jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen witzig
rudern oder bis bis ja bis luft rein
gelassen wird sozusagen seeluft frische
seeluft das ist dann auch so ein moment
wieder wo die crew dann
die die wirklich die die meeresluft dann
nochmal zum ersten mal auch wieder
einatmen und so wir sind wieder
angekommen auf der auf der erde und das
sind auch starke eindrücke für die für
die
astronauten dann nochmal wir kommen
gleich wieder zurück zu ihnen nach köln
fragen aber natürlich auch noch mal bei
ihren kollegen in oberpfaffenhofen nach
wie die diesen historischen moment
wahrgenommen haben und sprechen uns
gleich wieder und schalten jetzt also
nochmal zu dieter sabbat und thomas
gulich und sie schauen auch gespannt auf
den stream und hat gesehen wie wir alle
die kapsel ist aus dem wasser sind sie
genauso euphorisch und glücklich wie die
kollegen in köln
ja sicher also wir freuen uns dass das
alles so gut geklappt hat die einmal
frei landung und fallschirm im wasser
und dann die untersuchung dass alles
okay ist mit der kapsel und inzwischen
sieht man auf den bildern schön dass die
kapsel schon auf dem schiff gehievt
wurde sie befindet sich jetzt in diesem
lager platz wo die kapsel fest verankert
ist und dann werden die nächsten
schritte gemacht was willst du sollten
drachen des drachen es heißt das ja
genau die spezial ausdrücke habe ich
jetzt gar nicht gerade gehabt und da auf
dem das ist eben so gebaut dass die
kapsel im gegensatz zum wasser eben
nicht wackelt und fest auf dem schiff
steht und der nächste schritt ist jetzt
dann dass wir die kapsel mit diesem nest
zusammen in die nähe dieses tags fährt
wo man dann die die lupe auf machen kann
und dann kann man auch erst einmal nicht
nur über video die astronauten sehen
sondern die leute die eben das
bergungsteam hat die ersten ball dann
auch sichtkontakt zu den astronauten in
der kapsel und dann kann man mit ihnen
direkt reden es ist alles super gelaufen
wir freuen uns dass wir nach dieser
sechs monate mission wo wir uns um
matthias maurer kümmern dürften wirklich
auch wieder sehen dass er gut auf der
erde zurück ist und die nachbereitungen
dann starten kann und er wird er dann im
laufe des tages auch nach deutschland
zurückfliegen und wie wir vorher gehört
haben dann in köln ankommen und dort
dann die nächsten zwei wochen verbringen
und das ist dann der nächste schritt in
der mission die nachbereitung und jetzt
freuen wir uns darauf dass wir jetzt
noch ein paar schöne bilder sehen von
der kapsel und daneben den matthias
hoffentlich auch noch aussteigen sehen
den sie dann hoffentlich nicht allzu
langer zeit aus der kapsel rausholen
werden wo genau ist dieses deckt von dem
sie gesprochen haben wo die kapsel
hingezogen wird
die 14 meter weg also das sind ein paar
meter auf denen die kapsel jetzt auf dem
schiff sozusagen geschoben wird und dies
ist dann so ein zwei meter oder was
weiter 50 höhere stack das genauso
ausgerichtet ist dass die lücke die sie
ja sehen die jetzt eigentlich über dem
sich ein meter fünfzig über dem boden
befindet dass die dann ebenerdig oder
eben der kick ist und aus den auto neben
dann nicht noch ein meter fünfzig nach
unten klettern oben auf festen boden zu
kommen und auch schiff zu kommen wir
haben zwei fragen im stream die gehen in
eine ganz ähnliche richtung einmal
thomas theis und einer annabelle fragen
sich warum die personen die die kapsel
sichern schwere atemschutzmasken tragen
zum einen weiß ich gar nicht also das
sind so bei den taucher die sind einfach
mit irgendwann mal 'nen geräten
ausgestattet damit sie auch unter wasser
arbeiten können das zweite ist natürlich
dass das erste sicherungs team die
aufgabe hat zu untersuchen ob giftige
gas sowie treibstoff die eben noch in
der kapsel ist dann ausgetreten wäre
und die müssen natürlich dieses erste
team muss natürlich atemschutzgerät
dabei haben in dem fall dass es so wäre
dass die dann geschützt sind aber das
hat sich eben nicht herausgestellt dass
heißt gott sei dank nicht passiert dass
es auch wäre auch ein außergewöhnlicher
fall und dafür aber dafür haben eben
diese notfallausrüstung dabei damit die
ihnen dann nichts passiert und an
welcher stelle wird die kapsel geöffnet
vielleicht dass wir da schon mal wissen
ob wir jetzt bewegt sich wie sie gesagt
haben genau diese zehn meter
wahrscheinlich
also mit dem drachen mest wird die
kapsel praktisch in das schiff
reingefahren zu diesem zu dieser
plattform von dir der titel gesprochen
hat und dann wird daran gearbeitet dass
die türen aufgemacht die lücke die
übrigens jetzt interessanter weise
praktisch 180 tage braucht man einfach
zu weit ist das letzte mal aufgemacht
worden beim start
des doping module unter der nase
ok und jetzt sehen wir gerade eine
flüssigkeit ist das wasser was wetter
gerade benutzt
auf das bild schaffen wir haben hier so
leicht in verzug hier sehen das gar
nicht gesehen was da passiert ist das
habe aber
immer sieht jetzt schon genau das was
ich vorher gesagt habe die kapsel ist
jetzt an diesem tag angekommen dass die
luke ist jetzt sozusagen auf deck höhe
und der nächste schritt wird jetzt seien
eben die lücke zu öffnen und ein erstes
direktes wort mit den astronauten zu
wechseln und dann beginnt beginnt die
sequenz des ausstiegs der astronauten im
normalfall steigen zuerst die beiden
mittleren also der commander und der
pilot aus der kapsel aus und danach die
beiden passagiere die mit fliegenden
passagiere nämlich keiner berlin und
matthias maurer
und ja jetzt sind wir direkt ich weiß
nicht ob sie das jetzt auch gerade schon
sehen wenn sie meistens verzug haben
aber jetzt sehen wir jemand der also
tatsächlich schon oben an der luke
hantiert eine leiter wurde angestellt
ist dass das bild das sie auch haben ja
ja wir sehen dass man müsse leider
müssen uns umdrehen weil unser bild auf
unserem laptop hier etwas verzögert ist
aber wenn wir uns nach hinten schauen
dann sehen wir das ganz gut und das
sieht man jetzt eben die der
entscheidenden schritt das eben jetzt
jemand da sich an der luke
betätigt und dann wird das eben der
nächste schritt sein dass die lupe
darauf geht und ich vielleicht bekommen
wir auch gleich ein paar schöne bilder
von den astronauten da muss ich dann
darauf warten wie die nasa sozusagen die
bildregie macht und da sind wir
natürlich auch weit weg
und jetzt in der ich vermutet es wird
etwas gereinigt damit die eben der
abbrand beim wiedereintritt hinterlässt
natürlich spuren war sie die spuren ganz
deutlich
auf der kapsel und damit ins innere
davon nicht reinkommt wird die kapsel
vermutlich außen etwas abgespritzt und
dann das hat man damit dass
aber die spuren das macht der ganzen
kapsel ja nichts denn die soll
wiederverwertet werden richtig
nichts ist vielleicht der falsche
ausdruck natürlich müssen die spuren
beseitigt werden möglicherweise ein paar
hitzeschild teile ausgetauscht werden da
bin ich natürlich jetzt nicht der
experte dafür aber die kapsel wird auf
alle fälle wieder
hergerichtet und für den nächsten flug
dann
vorbereitet waren der sein wird das kann
ich jetzt momentan nicht sagen aber es
wird sicher einige monate dauern und
dann wird die kapsel wieder eingesetzt
und wie beim space shuttle auch
natürlich mit deutlich weniger aufwand
muss man die die kapsel natürlich
durchchecken und sicher sein dass alle
funktionen wieder so in eingebaut sind
und verwendbar sind das die nächste crew
wieder ohne probleme damit fliegen kann
sehen wir schon die erste fotograf und
die sich in stellung bringen ja was
sieht man im hintergrund
richtig genau das ist dass die
fotografen das begrüßungs team macht
sich jetzt sozusagen fertig das sind zum
einen fotografen es ist auch jemand
jeweils von den profis dabei also von
der esa von der nasa und ganz wichtig
auch ein flug arzt der natürlich jetzt
als erstes einen kurzen medizinischen
check macht mit der crew um
sicherzustellen dass gesundheitlich
alles ok ist jetzt mal dass google offen
ist sehr schön
ja das ist der nächste schritt und jetzt
sieht man links auf dem bild den ersten
boden team der ersten aus dem boden team
der mal in die kapsel reinzieht und mit
den astronauten redet und den ersten
kontakt den direkten kontakt aufnimmt
und natürlich eben fragt ob alles in
ordnung ist ob die normale sequenz
eingehalten werden kann und dann werden
wir sehen die nächsten schritte die dann
eben dazu führen die das denn auch
einander die astronauten aus der kapsel
rausgeholt werden
im prinzip die kapsel ist oft der erste
konnte der der mission man wird jetzt
gerade den schuss und den nebel gegen
schon ja
ja ja richtig
und da
scheint ja alles sehr
positiv abzulaufen es wird der ablauf
durchgesprochen über die nächsten
minuten und dann werden die
wahrscheinlich des sexes diese liegen
werden gebracht werden und einer nach
dem anderen steigt dann aus es ist ja so
im gegensatz zu visionen von vor 50
jahren als das training zu weil wir noch
nicht so gut war sind die astronauten ja
inzwischen gut trainiert auf der
raumstation es gibt viele geräte
laufbänder dort gewichtheber red ist ein
das simuliert gewicht heben natürlich
mit gummibändern auf der raumstation wo
die astronauten in der lage sind sich
fit zu halten das heißt nach sechs
monaten sind die normalerweise
gesundheitlich noch sehr gut
aufgestellt und haben
keine probleme aus der kapsel
herauszukommen da gab es für natürlich
ganz andere bilder aber da hat man da
ich deutliche fortschritte gemacht in
der ganzen trainings welt und in der
medizinischen betreuung der ersten
ordnung aber trotzdem sagten sie das
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich auf liegen
passieren also dann doch der ausstieg
ja sicher ist natürlich vorsichtig wie
der schmied vorher schon gesagt hat zum
beispiel das gleichgewichtsorgan muss
sich ja erst wieder an die ein g
umgebung gewöhnen und man will ja hier
nicht
unfälle provozieren indem er die zu
schnell dann wieder sozusagen als gehen
bringt und ist vorsichtig dass wir die
erste minute natürlich sie im sitzen
liegen dann transportiert aber die
adaption geht normalerweise sehr schnell
und wir werden wahrscheinlich im am
abend den matthias maurer schon wieder
aus dem flugzeug aussteigen sehen gehe
ich davon aus befindet dann werden wir
kleider mit dem kollegen und kunden
würde ich gar nicht was er leidet ja
sondern was das noch was leidet noch das
ist ja nicht nur die sondern auch der
herzmuskel das kardiovaskuläre system
und das ist natürlich was wir hier
aufpassen muss wenn ich den astronauten
gleich aufstellt dann kann es leicht
sein dass er einfach schwindlig wird und
der
zusammenbricht und deswegen macht man
das alte
damen um eben das physiologische system
des alten nicht zu überlasten gleich
nach der rückkehr nein da die
zeitverzögerung führt dazu dass wir uns
immer ein bisschen rein reden oder ich
ihnen viel mehr aber ich habe eine frage
bei uns im stream
die passt auch ganz gut dazu dominik ist
nett fragt gibt es eine obergrenze der
dauer die man auf der iss bleiben darf
also wegen kosmischer strahlung zum
beispiel fragt er sich oder vielleicht
auch eben weil es für den körper sonst
zu anstrengend werden könnte
natürlich wird auf die kosmische
strahlung wurde gesicht genommen und es
gibt viele
experimente oder auch subsysteme an bord
die die strahlung messen und daraus wird
dann abgeleitet wie hoch die belastung
für die astronauten war das war matthias
maurer sicher im normalen bereich
das liegt auch daran dass die niedrige
erdumlaufbahn immer noch im magnetfeld
der erde liegt und dadurch abgeschirmt
wird das heißt also es ist zwar höher
die belastung als hier unten auf der
erde aber zu meinem nicht so hoch wie am
mond und von daher und man hat
inzwischen die erfahrung und sehr viele
messgeräte auf der ss dass man das
abschätzen kann ob die
belastungsgrenze erreicht sein würde
und ob da irgendwelche maßnahmen
getroffen werden müssten aber das war
nicht der fall
und jetzt sieht es ganz schön nach
warten noch aus was wird gerade noch
besprochen was vermuten sie
also in der kapsel müssen auch eine
strukturelle einige strukturelle
veränderung noch gemacht werden dass ein
so genannte fortress trains drin die
erstmal ausgebaut werden können also es
muss auch die kapsel so hergerichtet
werden dass die astronauten überhaupt
herauskommen können und dann müssen die
astronauten natürlich los geschnallt
werden usw also dass noch einige sachen
die hier passieren die ersten proben
denke ich werden jetzt auch schon raus
genommen es gibt experimente gekühlt
herr untergebracht werden müssen und die
müssen ganz schnell halt sichergestellt
werden wieder in den kühlschrank das
sind ganz viele sachen die jetzt einfach
schritt für schritt es wären prozeduren
abgearbeitet die sicherstellen dass die
astronauten dann in kürze hoffentlich
aussteigen können und wie viel kontakt
hatten sie eigentlich zu
sagen sie bitte zuerst das ist schade
dass los
okay was jetzt gerade was die cumulus
gestalten was ich genommen ich wollte
sie gerade noch fragen mit der kontakt
zu matthias mittelmäßig
der von uns gab es regelmäßige kontakt
wir haben jede woche eine crew konferenz
durchgeführt mit mathias lauda wo man
die
weiteren abläufe besprochen hat oder
eben auch nach gesprochen hat was gut
oder vielleicht auch nicht ganz so gut
gelaufen ist das war
im regelmäßigen ablauf in den letzten
sechs monaten das ist natürlich jetzt
zum abschluss gekommen und alles
natürlich per
loops also mit audio kanälen hin und
manchmal auch per video kanäle die eben
dann deutlich mehr präsenz
vermitteln aber die natürlich auch
deutlich aufwendiger sind deswegen macht
man sich nicht jede woche das war unser
regelmäßiger kontakt und das ist
sozusagen auch das was über den normalen
kontakt hinaus geht die ihnen wir mit
den astronauten haben die nicht von der
esa sind da gibt es jeden tag eine delle
planning konferenz wo jedes
kontrollzentrum des fds es mit wirkt
eben kurz mit den asiatinnen austauschen
kann über das tagesgeschäft was in
diesem tag gemacht werden soll sie alle
konnten aber er hatte ja bitte sagen sie
man sieht jetzt schon die nächsten
vorbereitungen es ist eine rampe
angelegt worden und wie toll ich vorher
schon gesagt hat dass abschnallen geht
weiter und wie man sie beschäftigen sich
die bodencrew als erstes mit den beiden
mittleren osten
mit dem commander und dem piloten also
nah und fern und die werden dann als
erstes aussteigen wenn die ganzen
anderen vorbereitungen aus durchgeführt
sind ich wollte gerade noch sagen dass
wir alle aber ja die mitte ist ja auch
okay die erste liga ist schon da und
bist also jetzt gleich jemand auf der
liege league können wir vielleicht mal
zusammen schauen auf meinem bildschirm
wir alle hier im stream denn matthias
maurer hat uns alle teilhaben lassen an
seiner mission und ganz viel gepostet
hier zb bei instagram und hier hat er
ich öffne mal einen beitrag vorerst zwei
tagen fotos gepostet von sich in
kompression hosen die er also unter
seinem space ex raumanzug trägt um den
kreislauf beim wiedereintritt in die
schwerkraft der erde zu unterstützen
schreibt er und da sieht man ihnen im
poster in dieser speziellen hose nach
oben auf der raumstation
also da hat er sich scheinbar auch
vorbereitet diese weise soll ja
verhindern also dass sich das blut in
den beinen staut und wir können also
noch mal zurück schauen ob jetzt auf der
liege schon was passiert da aber kurz
davor
also als erstes
kommen die beiden vorderen personen aus
der kapsel das sehen wir hier und
vielleicht noch mal nach
oberpfaffenhofen dann auch noch mal mit
der frage also ich hab eben gerade
gezeigt auf den bildern von matthias
maurer r trägt also nicht nur den anzug
sogar unter dem anzug auch spezielle
kleidung hat er verraten wie er sich
sonst vorbereitet hat für die rückreise
wir hatten eben noch letzte fragen an
ihn er hat natürlich die übergabe
gemacht mit seiner nachfolgerin samantha
cristoforetti
die jedem nahtlos eben sogar mit einer
woche überlappung
dieser experimente weiterführt und die
jetzt dann im nächsten sechs monaten mit
uns zusammenarbeiten wird und mit ihrer
mission die
natürlich den fokus mehr auf italienisch
elemente legen wird aber die natürlich
viele leser experimenten matthias maurer
angefangen hat fortsetzen wird erst dann
hat das ausgestiegen da haben wir schon
ein schönes bild
gleich sieben ja er sitzt und das ist
eben die vorsichtsmaßnahme dass man eben
dieser aktion
zulässt und den astronauten zeit gibt in
der sich in die neue neue alte umgebung
wieder einzufinden
und das sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht
mehr lange dauern wenn jetzt mal der
erste ausgestiegen ist sollte die
prozedur in wenigen minuten dann auch
durchgeführt werden und dann sehen wir
hoffentlich auch in wenig kürzer zeit
auch den matthias maurer dann ihre
kapsel verlässt und daumen hoch hat er
gezeigt also das hat schon mal wunderbar
funktioniert
und jetzt dann direkt die nächste person
nämlich an
die nächste person nach unseren
informationen wird der matthias maurer
als letztes aussteigen ja mal gespannt
genau sind wir mal gespannt und haben
noch ein bisschen zeit noch einmal über
das letzte halbe jahr zu sprechen denn
sie haben das ja begleitet also auch mit
begleitet diese mission und was war denn
für sie vielleicht auch ein spannender
moment denn ich habe gelesen dass
tatsächlich dieser außeneinsatz an der
iss wohl für matthias maurer auch
besonders war uns besonders aufregend
besonders knifflig war hat er ihnen das
auch so berichtet
überdies da haben wir es nicht intensiv
darüber gesprochen das lief mehr auf der
fachlichen ebene natürlich der austausch
er hat ja für uns speziell auch eben
außen an bord für columbus arbeiten
erledigt da haben wir uns natürlich mit
ihm darauf vorbereitet und nachher haben
wir natürlich gleich
überprüft ob das auch richtig geklappt
hat es gab ja da die fehlenden kabel bei
für diese betrieb der bartholomäer
plattform die
wurden
jetzt von matthias maurer eingesteckt
und inzwischen haben wir auch gehört
dass das erfolgreich war und diese der
checkout dieser plattform läuft jetzt
ganz nominell und wir erwarten dass wir
anfang nächsten jahres dafür dann erste
experimente bekommen und das ist ja auch
eine der neuen teile auf der raumstation
das ist nämlich eine eine kommerzielle
plattform die von airbus betrieben wird
und das ist sozusagen der neue schritt
in der bemannten raumfahrt dass wir auch
eben kommerzielle anbieter zulassen wie
hier die kapsel die von spacex geflogen
wird so ist dieser auch hat inzwischen
kommerzielle anbieter an bord genommen
und da eben auch das mit in die
erweiterung der möglichkeiten der
bemannten raumfahrt in zwischenzeit
haben wir auch einen zweiten ausstieg
gesehen meine ich sehr haben sie
angesprochen also die us kollegen sind
zuerst dran gewesen tom marshburn hatten
sie gesagt und die zweite person war
dass keller berlin oder raja karim eine
ich richtig
er ist die sind die beiden ersten
gewesen die in der mitte sitzen wie
gesagt sind beiden pilot und commander
und die dürften als erstes aussteigen
und jetzt kommen die seitlichen beiden
astronauten dran die auf die seitlichen
sitzen sie eben wie man ja zu beginn
unsere übertragung gesehen hat als das
bild von innen von der kapsel war sitzt
eben der matthias maurer links außen und
deswegen muss er sich noch etwas
gedulden bis er dann auch geschnallt
wird und auch aus der kapsel aussteigen
dort muss auch der langen zeit glaube
ich sind die paar minuten noch gut zu
verstehen das stimmt oder vielleicht
auch gerade nicht aber bevor es für ihn
nach deutschland geht was sie hat dort
vor ort als wirklich direkt nächstes sie
planten auf dieser liege und dann wohin
geht's dann
es gibt auf dem schiff für jede nation
aus in einen raum wo er dann auch eben
sein anzug ausziehen kann und dieses
normale
die kleidung wieder für die erde
heranziehen kann
und dann wird eines weit wir gehört
haben ein kurzer check hier macht ein
health check ein gesundheitscheck und
dann geht es aber auch schon ziemlich
schnell sagt spätestens einer stunde mit
dem hubschrauber dann an land wo die
nächsten untersuchungen durchgeführt
werden und dann mit einem flugzeug
richtung
der linken air force base wo dann das
flugzeug das deutsche flugzeug schon
landet das dann den mathias lauda zurück
nach deutschland bringt
gerade noch mal ein bisschen hier im
netz geschaut sollen sich dann die wege
zwischen
da treffen sich dann die wege zwischen
den vier astronauten die drei
amerikanischen kollegen und kolleginnen
werden dann natürlich in usa bleiben und
dort weiter betreut werden und er ist
vorerst einmal in köln und wird die
ersten zwei wochenende die help
verbringen später dann natürlich werden
sie natürlich auch wieder gemeinsam die
nachbereitung machen genau in dieses
europäische astronautenzentrum nach köln
zu dem missionsleiter zu herrn schmid
schalten wir auch noch mal aber erst
nach dem ausstieg natürlich von matthias
maurer dann können wir mit ihm am ende
der sendung noch mal darüber sprechen
wie es dann also in deutschland
weitergeht jetzt für den moment bleiben
wir natürlich noch bei ihnen und bei
diesen bei dem spannenden moment wann er
denn tatsächlich aussteige ich schaue
noch mal hier in unsere fragen im stream
und zwar schreibt roland meier der
wievielte space ex flug zur iss ist das
jetzt eigentlich gibt es überhaupt noch
andere die sie hinfahren
anfahren
also der erste teil ist das war jetzt
die crew drei das heißt der dritte
offizielle flug der dragon der crew
trading zur iss und davor gab es eine
demo flug das insgesamt ist es der
vierte bemannte flug der tracking zur
iss inzwischen hat er auch schon der
fünfte stattgefunden mit der
der samantha cristoforetti und dazu muss
man natürlich das sind jetzt die flüge
die die nasa bezahlt und dazu gab es
noch einen flug vor gerade vier wochen
einen den ersten privaten finanzierten
flug zur iss die sogenannte aktion 1
mission die auch die crew trägen benutzt
hat also sind inzwischen schon sechs
crews an der iss angedockt
und dann schaue ich noch mal nach
weiteren fragen oder kommentaren hier
schreibt die blogs bei youtube ich wäre
lieber im als hier auf der erde gut das
ist nur ein paar wenigen vergönnt wobei
durch sein unternehmen die specs space
existiert auch immer mehr jetzt sind wir
die dritte person sie erst mal richtig
wer ist das die dritte person ist schon
draußen und die dritte person ist schon
raus aus tag absolut und jetzt stehen
wir jetzt gerade hier gesehen haben mit
das bild bei uns wieder weg ist dann
wirklich der europäische flugangst der
jetzt auf den matthias maurer erwartet
dass er der nächste der aussteigt jetzt
an der matthias maurer sehen hier hier
wieder gerade es wird ganz vorsichtig
heraus gehoben das sollte der matthias
maurer jetzt sind
wir sind gespannt
nicht mehr lange dauern
er ist natürlich die sich jetzt hier
drinnen und draußen versperrt aber
gleich werden wir sehen
genau das sollte er schon draußen sein
jetzt hoffen wir dass die nasa das bild
umschaltet dann können wir ihnen auch
draußen sie ist gemeinsam
dass sie bei ihm und zwei comeback
mathias lauda und wir freuen uns dass es
ihm gut geht und jetzt kann er sich
wieder auf das leben auf der erde nach
601 schwerelosigkeit vorbereiten 21 der
sachen die er gesagt hat die immer am
meisten wo er sich am meisten darauf
heute ein frische luft auf der erde
wieder schnaufen wir haben im tor
matthias maurer denke ich eine besondere
beziehung im kontrollzentrum weil er bei
uns im team lange als europe.com
mitgearbeitet hat als als derjenige im
team der mit den astronauten redet und
da freut es uns natürlich jetzt
besonders dass er seine erste mission
als astronaut auch jetzt abgeschlossen
hat dann wünschen wir ihnen heute einen
schönen tag an dem sie feiern können im
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
in oberpfaffenhofen vielen dank an
dieter sabbat und thomas uhlig dann wir
schalten jetzt ins europäische
astronautenzentrum nach köln wo nach wie
vor der missionsleiter für uns steht
bereit steht und wir natürlich jetzt
auch noch mal nachfragen er ist
ausgestiegen matthias marx draußen und
wie fühlt sich an
super also scheint ihm den umständen
entsprechend gut zu gehen danke
gewohnten ja also sieht sehr gut aus und
bisher hat alles reibungslos geklappt
offen sie glaube ich wir sind
erleichtert und froh dass er zurück ist
und dann erwarten wir einen mit heute
abend auf jeden fall hier in köln und da
dieser in die rekonvaleszenz irgendwie
in sandy habt gehen
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
in köln wir haben viele kollegen sagten
ja gerade erfreut sich sehr
erfreut sich glaube ich auch eine dusche
der näherte da oben viertelliter wasser
für eine dusche am tag das war auch
beeindruckend und ich glaube da erinnert
sich jetzt so einige ist ein frischer
salat und so das sind die sachen die wir
so mitbekommen haben wenn wir sprechen
konnten also ich glaube das wird ein
fest hier oder ja also da die die
entbehrungen die man da oben hinnehmen
musste dafür natürlich eine tolle
aussicht und ein einzigartiger
arbeitsplatz
und das gibt es jetzt wieder frischer
salat auch mal eine cola vielleicht oder
sprudel und ne pizza so was alles was
von
wert oder vermisst wurde die letzten
sechs monate und dass das kommt jetzt
nach und nach wieder die nächsten tage
denke ich ja er hat ja auch sagen dass
essen dabei also aus seiner heimat in
den dosen also ist man hat wohl fürs all
ganz gut gegessen habe
das auf jeden fall also die die
küche sozusagen oder die die
nahrungsmittel die sind sehr sehr gut
geworden auch geschmacklich und auch das
vor allen dingen das bonus foto und die
saarländischen spezialitäten die werden
dann geteilt mit den kollegen mit der
groß das ist so ein soziales event immer
gegessen wird zusammen und das ist auch
wichtig für die motivation das gute gute
essen
hält auch da oben leib und seele
zusammen das ist so er ist saarländer
susanne durchs angesprochen deswegen
hast du ihn auch insbesondere begleitet
du bist studioleiterin bei uns im studio
im saarland aber bisher dahin
zurückkehren kann das dauert noch eine
weile zeichnen sie uns vielleicht noch
mal kurz den weg vorher schmid jetzt die
nächsten zwei wochen was passiert dann
genau mit matthias maurer dann treffen
sie auf ihn
ja also wir werden ihnen heute abend
abholen am flughafen wenn er ankommt
wurde er gesagt er geht jetzt mit dem
hubschrauber rüber und dann nach tampa
und dann im flieger nach ellington air
force base bei houston und dann mit der
flugbereitschaft eben hier nach köln zum
militärischen teil dort erwarten wir
ihnen heute abend und dann kommt er
hierher an sandy habe und hier ist wenn
man so will
eine wohnung eingerichtet oder in einen
raum für ihn eingerichtet wo er dann
heute auf jeden fall erstmal bleibt und
auch die nächsten zwei drei wochen hier
regelmäßig untersucht wird das wird
natürlich jetzt in den ersten zwei
wochen
jeden tag sein und da wird alles
gecheckt also der gesamte organismus
alle untersuchungen gleichgewichtsorgan
blut urin alles was was man medizinisch
machen kann um die werte zu erheben das
ist ganz wichtig dass es so die
sogenannte baseline data collection das
geht auch dann in datenbanken einen
natürlich
daten geschützt auch das ist ganz
wichtig
und eben war
auch kenntnisse zu erhalten wie wirkt
sich die schwerelosigkeit bei jedem
individuum welches fliegt aus
langfristig und
er hat oben ja unterschiedliche
programme auch gemacht ernährung
fitness ja das wird alles geprüft alles
untersucht und dann eben korreliert die
daten miteinander abgeglichen und das
ist ganz wichtig dass man sich zukünftig
da noch besser im training optimieren
kann noch besser vielleicht auch die
ernährung abstimmen kann auf solche
langzeitmissionen stichwort ist auch
vorher angeklungen wie lange hält inhalt
hält man so eine mission aus also ein
halbes jahr ist schon herausforderung
das geht mittlerweile aber ganz gut ein
jahr wird schon extrem herausforderung
noch mal auf der iss
und das ist aber beabsichtigt wenn man
richtung mond mars gehen will dann
braucht man solche zeiträume und dafür
sind unter anderem diese daten notwendig
dass man training ernährung und
protokolle so aufeinander abstimmen kann
und den menschen auch wieder sicher
zurückbringen kann dann und ja das wird
dann hier über den nächsten zwei drei
wochen gemacht ist
genauso wie man sich an die
schwerelosigkeit anpassen muss im all
muss man sich rundum erdboden auch
wieder adaptieren gleichgewichtsorgan
der der blutkreislauf herz
herz-kreislauf-system
atmung alles muss muss sich wieder
anpassen immunsystem ganz wichtig
und das dauert eben seine zeit das
sollte hier ein kontrollierter umgebung
passieren jetzt ist jedes individuum
natürlich anders
jeder mensch reagiert anders und wenn er
in guter verfassung ist dann kann er
vielleicht schon nach zwei drei tagen zu
hause wieder schlafen muss dann aber
jeden tag hier reinkommen und und dann
eben hier auch sein sein programm
durchführen und ich denke mal so nach
drei wochen vier wochen
ist er dann soweit wieder hergestellt
dann geht es an die die briefings wird
er wahrscheinlich in die usa gehen
erstmal bei nasa bericht erstatten und
mit dem team so ein erstes debriefing
machen und dann haben wir ihn auch
irgendwann später im jahr noch mit
verschiedenen terminen dann kommt die
sogenannte post flight phase mit mit
vielen pr terminen wissenschaftliche die
briefings auch und da werden wir ihn
dann auch sehen auf jeden fall dann
wünschen dir ein schönes wiedersehen
heute abend vielen dank volker schmid
missionsleiter das dlr und vielen dank
susanne freitag du hast außerdem eine
doku für uns gemacht über maurers zeit
auf der iss die können alle sich
anschauen in der zdf mediathek vielen
dank für die zeit und einordnung heute
morgen
und wir sagen natürlich auch vielen dank
an euch fürs zu sehen alle die es so
lange ausgehalten haben und auch so früh
aufgestanden sind natürlich wir schauen
nochmals zusammen jetzt gerade auf die
spektakulären bilder matthias maurer der
jetzt mit dieser kleinen kapsel hier
sieht es wirklich noch eine winzige
kapseln und fallschirme vier stück oben
dran ganz sicher gelandet ist und große
freude bei der nasa dass das also so gut
geglückt ist und
er wieder sicher mit seinen
amerikanischen kolleginnen und kollegen
zurück auf der erde ist
zum ende greife ich noch gerne ein
kommentar hier von christian kreuzer
youtube auf der schreibt der frieden
zwischen den nationen auf der iss so
viele verschiedene da oben sollte auf
der erde ebenfalls vorherrschen wünscht
er sich und manuela kommentiert das meer
der himmel auf erden damit entlasse ich
euch in den tag und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss